[Music]
thank you very much welcome to this
debate the major questions then within
our debate today are whether we should
accept that the most important things in
life are beyond language or can we find
the right words to say everything even
if we don't yet know them and
fortunately we have very lucid quorum of
speakers to discuss this Hilary Lawson
is a post-postmodern philosopher and an
outspoken critic of realism on my far
left I have Kenya shirne bombs felled
who is a professor of philosophy and a
victim Stein expert and here I have
Stanley fish who is a literary critic
and legal scholar and he regularly
contributes to the New York Times so I'm
gonna pose this question which I cited
in the opening remarks and I'll start
first with Hillary Lawson can we find
the right words for everything even if
we don't yet know what they are Hillary
thank you Thank You Joan so we have the
impression don't we that we can describe
almost everything we look around the
room we see people we see objects and so
forth even to the extent that sometimes
the world can seem a rather dull place
where we have everything taped but I'm
going to argue that this is an illusion
and that almost everything is left
unsaid now I don't say this because I'm
somehow attached to a mystical notion of
the world that I'd like there to be more
I say it in a rather nitty-gritty
rationalist way that if we set out to
try and describe what the things are
that we see and have contact with we
find ourselves unable to do so I guess
the idea that language describes reality
and describes things out there in the
world is a very sort of common sense
view and in the context of philosophy
it's usually described as philosophical
realism this view now one first
indication of the problem with
philosophical realism
is that all of those different things we
see out there you can take any one of
them and we can describe them in some
other way so you know this cup here for
example what else might it be well it
could be a container I might say oh well
past the water I notice it actually says
I'm not a plastic cup so presumably it's
something else entirely it could be it's
it's a bomb yes indeed well it is it's
certainly an intellectual bomb hopefully
it could be the lattice of molecules it
could be the residue from the Big Bang
it could be an environmental strategy
there's no limit to the number of ways
we can hold this bit of the world
usually realists try and get round this
by saying well what's going on here is
all of these different descriptions are
of some underlying thing but if you go
and look for the underlying thing if
it's a physical thing
we can't find it in the terms of the
current scientific story we'd end up
with quarks and leptons and fluxes of
energy not not really very credible as
underlying things and so again some
realists have tried to propose that
there's a transcendental thing that
somehow beyond all of these specific
things which accounts for all of these
different ways that we can describe the
world now I want to propose that none of
that is viable and that instead we
should think of the world as being open
and instead of thinking of it being made
up somehow ultimately a bits out there
we think here of being open and we
closed that openness of the world with
linguistic metaphor so I think we also
do it with sensory metaphors as it
happens but anyway we close the openness
of the world and those metaphors or more
specifically more technically are
described as closures enable us to
intervene and if we hold this as a cup
I can then elaborate that metaphor I can
say well what sort of cup is it where
was it made what was its design all of
those sorts of things if instead I hold
it as a lattice of biological molecules
I said well what is the shape of this
lattice what's the relationship between
them so each of our closures builds out
as a sort of nest of more detailed
versions and those different metaphors
enable us to intervene if we hold this
as a cup we will then be able to
intervene in it in a certain way we'll
be able to ask to pass it and so forth
if instead we we hold it as something
else then we will change the way we
intervene so how when we move from one
closure to another we change how we
intervene in the world my last thought
to leave you with is that some of you
may think well I'm rather attached to
this idea that there's some underlying
real behind all of these metaphors and I
don't really want to give it up and to
that I would say well for the past
couple of millennia we've not been able
to under Phi the underlying things
there's no viable theory of how we could
do so there's no realist theory of
language which would enable us to
identify these things and there's no
realistic prospect that at some point
we're going to be able to identify them
in the future
so instead if we hold the world as being
open there's an indefinite amount of
potential potential to be able to hold
the world differently to generate new
closures new ways of holding the world
that enable us to intervene and
hopefully make the world a better place
Thank You Hilary so I'll turn now to
Jenni return bombs felled with the same
question can we find the right words for
everything even if we don't yet know
what they are Kenya okay thank you I
think we need first of all to
distinguish a number of different
questions so just already responding a
tiny bit to what Hillary just said I
think we need to distinguish between the
question can there be one true
description of the world and the
question can everything be described
so those are two different questions you
might answer no to the first question
you might think there is no one true
description of the world that has
priority over other possible true
descriptions so that's one response you
might make but that's a very different
answer to a different question when
you're perhaps wondering is there such a
thing as the in principle inexpressible
so one way of understanding the question
that Joana has just asked is as the
question well is there anything that
transcends language are there certain
things that we just cannot put into
words so I'm going to respond to that
question is there anything inexpressible
is it possible that we could find
something that would resist any form of
conceptualization any rendering into a
system of linguistic signs and my answer
to that question is going to be no so
I'm with the later Wittgenstein on
language who thinks there is nothing
beyond the bounds of sense except
nonsense
so there's no such thing as the in
principle inexpressible and it's
interesting that that would be the
response of the later Wittgenstein
because the early bit constrain had
quite a different view I mean some of
you might be familiar with it
constraints early work the Tractatus so
in that work he actually famously argued
that all the things that really matter
in human life art ethics religion all
the the big serious things they are all
ineffable they're all imprints in
expressible so he completely changed his
mind
in the later philosophy about that and
it's interesting to kind of just spend a
moment thinking about why vit can shine
had this view in the first place in the
early work I mean you might think you
know it's a crazy view is you know can
it be right that really we can't say
anything about art ethics and religion I
mean you know what of all the great
artists can PO
etc down if you can't talk about these
things then you know what what are we
doing here so you know you've all come
to the wrong place we actually can't
talk about these things that would be
that would be really depressing if that
were true now the reason why Vic and I
thought this in his early work is
because he thought that language has an
essence so that there is one central
thing that language tries to do and in
the early work sort of to put it in a
nutshell
he thought the essence of languages to
describe the world and crucially to give
you a description a factual description
of the way things are and because he
thought that because he thought that the
essence of language is basically to
describe the facts to provide linguistic
models of the facts for that reason he
thought ethics art and religion can't be
put into words because of course these
domains are not necessarily primarily
facts tainting I mean ethics tells you
about what you ought to do not about
what is the case for more debates talks
and interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you